Donc on a commencé à considérer ce qu'on appelle une étude apologétique pour les créationnismes,
c'est-à-dire on va sortir du cadre de la source d'autorité principale qui est les Écritures.
Voici le travail de l'homme de la Bible, voici le travail de théologiens, de pasteurs et de théologiens qui nous sommes tous.
Si nous sommes des vrais chrétiens, on doit reconnaître que toute Écriture est la parole de Dieu,
c'est une inspiration plénaire, une inspiration littérale, verbale,
c'est-à-dire chaque mot, chaque particule a été inspirée par Dieu, par le Saint-Esprit,
et son ensemble est autoritaire et inspiré.
Et donc c'est la Bible elle-même qui doit dicter la manière dont on interprète chaque portion,
et on a pris le travail, c'est le plus nécessaire au sein d'une Église,
de vous démontrer dans la Bible surtout,
que tous les auteurs bibliques qui font référence à Genèse, au premier chapitre de Genèse,
les font de manière historique, littérale,
et donc sur la base interne d'interprétation biblique, au-dedans de la Bible même,
c'est impossible d'interpréter Genèse sans que ce soit littéral, y compris les jours de la création.
En plus, on a rajouté que l'Église orthodoxe, au long de toute l'histoire,
a toujours traité Genèse comme littérale dans ses confessions,
c'est-à-dire toutes les confessions des fois,
même si aujourd'hui on va dire, moi j'adopte Westminster,
ou la confession baptiste de 1689,
et ils disent qu'aujourd'hui on peut affirmer ces documents,
tout en ayant des accords,
car ils ne précisent pas que les jours soient littéraux,
quand ils disent que Dieu a créé toutes les choses en six jours.
Mais c'est clair,
que si nous allons vers l'histoire,
étudier la position de tous les rédacteurs des confessions,
qu'ils avaient l'intention, les auteurs de la confession,
que ça soit pris de manière littérale.
Donc ça n'a toujours pas quelque chose d'unonymement présent
dans tous les théologiens de l'histoire,
que l'interprétation de Genèse soit littérale pour les récits de la création,
mais en termes confessionnels, c'est unonyme.
Toutes les confessions au long de l'histoire l'ont fait.
Et la majorité prédominante de tous les théologiens conservateurs
ont eu aussi cette position.
Et donc pour nous, le plus important, c'était de vous montrer
que nous n'avons pas besoin,
et c'est même une abomination devant la Bible et l'histoire,
de ne pas traiter Genèse chapitre 1 comme littéral.
C'est une aberration par rapport à l'orthodoxie chrétienne historique.
Et encore plus surprenant, c'est que la position
qui dans les dernières générations a apparue,
qui va contre ces évidences,
qui va contre les fils conducteurs de l'histoire de l'Église,
c'est quelque chose qui est apparu de manière très récente.
Car même ceux qui veulent réclamer Augustin
comme n'ayant pas une position littérale,
son indice n'était pas de suggérer une terre vieille,
ni d'accorder avec quelque chose qui n'était pas de son époque.
Donc, dans les courants, c'est plutôt à cause de la popularisation
des théories d'évolution et les pressions culturelles
qui ont plié certains théologiens.
Donc là, on a traité comme il faut.
La chose principale, ce sont les évidences bibliques,
les évidences de l'histoire de l'Église.
Donc ça, c'était ma fonction, mon travail en tant que pasteur,
en tant que théologien.
Et là, je passe à quelque chose qui peut fortifier une foi déjà existante,
mais qui n'a pas la capacité d'engendrer la foi.
Donc on vient de prier basé sur la prière d'Étienne,
la prédication d'Étienne.
Et la prédisposition naturelle des incrédules,
c'est de ne pas accepter la vérité des dieux.
Et la raison principale que la Bible nous donne
pour les refus de reconnaître les récits bibliques,
c'est qu'il y a toujours un agenda corrompu derrière.
Et donc, l'apologétique créationniste,
c'est notre objectif dans ces deux dernières leçons,
c'est pour chercher les arguments,
car je vous ai dit que non seulement c'est une violence
contre la Bible,
et c'est une violence contre l'histoire du christianisme,
de ne pas interpréter littéralement en jeunesse,
mais c'est aussi une démonstration d'ignorance
vis-à-vis à la science elle-même.
Et moi, je ne suis pas un expert envers la science,
mais je me suis consacré quand même
à étudier quelques experts
qui présentent ce qu'est la vraie science
et comment la vraie science,
elle joue beaucoup plus pour confirmer
les jeunesses littérales,
la terre jeune par exemple.
Et donc, on va considérer,
donc ça c'est la fonction des croyants,
de l'Église, des pasteurs,
et ça c'est la fonction parfois
des quelques chrétiens
ou des scientifiques honnêtes tout simplement.
Car même entre les non-chrétiens scientifiques
d'intégrité intellectuelle,
on va trouver plusieurs
qui n'ont pas embrassé la théorie de l'évolution
et qui ont toujours mis en question,
même à l'époque d'Arving,
même à l'époque d'Arving non seulement ça,
mais même lui-même dans ses livres
en reconnaissant la difficulté
d'éprouver ses thèses, ses théories.
Et donc, c'est aussi une question d'ignorance
par rapport aux données réelles de la science,
de la logique, de la philosophie, etc.
Et donc, là, je vais m'aventurer
à considérer avec vous,
sachant que ce n'est pas mon air d'expertise,
et je vous laisse tout simplement
cette leçon en vous présentant
quelques directions,
à vous de vous approfondir,
car si vous voulez rentrer plus
dans les détails scientifiques
de certaines choses,
je ne suis pas capable,
mais je crois que la manière
dont je suis structuré,
c'est suffisant pour que vous puissiez
aller plus loin
et que ça puisse confirmer
ces évidences.
Avant de rentrer dans ces arguments
apologétiques,
on a considéré
les théories d'origine prédominante,
donc c'est soit au long
de toute l'histoire de l'humanité,
à partir du moment où on a commencé
à mettre en question,
et c'est depuis toujours,
depuis le début de l'enregistrement historique,
les êtres humains
cherchent les réponses métaphysiques,
les réponses par rapport
à l'origine des choses.
Et donc il y a deux théories
prédominantes au long de l'histoire,
soit une origine intelligente,
une divinité,
que ce soit par la mythologie,
la philosophie ou la religion,
il y a toujours ces courants.
Et de l'autre côté,
une mentalité qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
plutôt comme naturaliste,
ceux qui vont suggérer plutôt
soit la préexistence de la matière,
soit la génération spontanée de la matière.
Donc si on a ces deux théories des bases,
c'est intéressant de remarquer
l'histoire des théories des origines.
Donc on a fait la semaine dernière
juste une considération
de la période où ces théories
ont été un peu plus formalisées,
même si elles étaient plus structurées,
un peu plus empiriques, scientifiques,
mais elles restaient quand même
assez mythologiques.
Mais c'était la période
de la philosophie grecque classique.
Et donc juste,
ce qui est intéressant pour nous
de résumer,
c'est qu'on a eu pas mal
des théories très archaïques
qui allaient suggérer
que toutes les choses sont venues
soit de l'eau,
soit des quatre éléments,
des bases,
les feux, la terre,
les vents, etc.
Et de l'autre côté,
dans cette même période,
il y a eu d'autres noms.
Et il suffit de dire
que du bon côté de la force,
on avait Socrate,
Platon et Aristote.
Et de l'autre côté,
des autres philosophes
qui étaient assez respectables,
mais on sait très bien
qu'ils n'étaient pas
à la hauteur
de ces philosophes.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que ce sont des choses
qui sont là
depuis la philosophie grecque
pour qu'on apprenne
que lorsqu'on arrive
à Darwin,
on n'est pas en train
de contempler un scientifique
qui est en train
de regarder tout simplement
les évidences objectives
et de suggérer sa théorie.
Il était plutôt en train
de prêter
ces théories
qui étaient déjà anciennes
et de chercher
par ces paradigmes,
c'est-à-dire
par ces présupposés,
il va chercher
à développer
d'une manière
un peu plus empirique
et scientifique,
mais il avait déjà son biais.
Et donc à partir de là,
on a parlé des conflits,
des paradigmes,
ceux qui veulent
enlever Dieu
de l'équation
comme si on était
dans un univers
dont les relations
des causes-effets
sont dans un système
fermé
sans la possibilité
d'intervention divine.
Donc là,
on doit s'obliger
à croire
dans la création
spontanée de la matière
ou la préexistence
de la matière
ou au moins
la préexistence
de certains éléments
qui ont pu
peut-être
provoquer une explosion.
Et donc là,
on a les conflits
des paradigmes.
C'est juste pour vous rappeler
que quand on parle
des théories
à propos des origines,
on n'est plus
dans les champs
de la science.
Pourquoi ?
Car la science,
elle travaille
sur la base
de la reproduction
et l'observation
des phénomènes.
Et les phénomènes créationnels,
on n'a jamais observé.
Et donc on a des théories
qu'on essaie
de corroborer
par les évidences
qui sont là,
qu'on observe.
Mais si on va encore
un peu plus loin,
on peut dire aussi
que pour plus
que dans une perspective
d'explication,
on puisse percevoir
par exemple
des similarités
entre un singe
et un être humain,
si on est déjà
dans un paradigme,
on va dire
l'homme a évolué
dans le singe,
on va pointer
quelques similarités
comme évidence.
Mais par là,
je dois avoir
déjà un présupposé.
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
la science ?
On n'a jamais observé
un singe
se transforme
en être humain,
donc ça,
ce n'est pas la science.
Et en plus,
nous aurions pu proposer
une autre théorie
pour expliquer
ces similarités.
On a été créé
par les mêmes dieux
pour habiter
dans les mêmes univers,
dans les mêmes
environnements,
et Dieu a voulu
ainsi.
Et donc,
la similarité
des choses,
c'est la même similarité
comme quelqu'un a dit,
on ne peut pas présupposer
qu'une Ferrari
ait évolué
à partir
d'un Citroën
jusqu'à,
on voit qu'ils ont
quatre roues
ou un moteur similaire.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est qu'une chose
n'a pas évolué
à l'autre,
évolué à l'autre.
OK ?
Et donc là,
il faut qu'on soit conscient
en fait,
de la perspective
des approches.
Donc là,
on a la considération
des approches
apologétiques
envers les créationnismes,
c'est notre intérêt.
Et ces approches,
elles peuvent être
des trois ordres principaux.
Donc,
le premier,
c'est d'évaluer
l'évidence scientifique
pour démontrer
qu'elle joue
contre la théorie
évolutionniste.
Donc,
c'est une implosion
de la théorie
évolutionniste.
Il y a plein
d'arguments comme ça.
Pour nous,
je pense qu'il est plus
positif,
c'est soit
de considérer
de quelle manière
ces arguments
jouent dans la direction
positive
des récits bibliques
sur la création.
Et là,
si on croit vraiment
que la Bible
est la parole de Dieu,
même si Genèse 1
n'est pas très détaillée,
il est suffisant
selon Dieu
et il reste quand même
un enregistrement scientifique.
car c'est Dieu lui-même
qui était
le créateur,
l'observateur,
celui qui a vu,
celui qui a fait,
qui nous a donné
son enregistrement.
Donc,
pour nous,
c'est de la science
tout de suite.
Mais en plus,
quand on considère
les troisièmes possibilités,
c'est des,
au fur et à mesure
où on lit Genèse,
par exemple,
et les récits bibliques
sur la création
ou les récits bibliques
qui sont liés
à la science,
nous allons,
au fur et à mesure,
évoquer
quelques évidences bibliques.
Donc là,
c'est mon approche préférée.
Il y a plusieurs livres
qui font de cette manière,
des études bibliques
pour faire même
avec la famille
ou à la mesure
où on voit
quelques détails
de la création,
par exemple,
et l'homme
a été créé
à partir
dans l'original,
les mots
veulent dire plutôt
pour nous
ce qui serait aujourd'hui
les atomes de la terre.
Ce n'est pas tout simplement
la poussière,
c'est la conception
de la particule minimale.
OK ?
Et donc,
il y a des scientifiques
qui vont là
chercher
et démontrer
comment dans la
constitution moléculaire
humaine,
nous avons plusieurs éléments
qui sont très similaires
à celui de l'argile.
Par exemple,
le moment où Dieu
va endormir Adam
pour faire Ève
et pourquoi
il les tire
de sa côte.
Et là,
les cellules couches
qui se trouvent
dans la...
l'un des endroits
les plus favorables
pour enlever
des cellules couches
pour faire un clonage
ment,
sort de là.
Et donc là,
on va de manière
très intéressante.
Et donc,
il y a des scientifiques
qui vont dire
que c'est comme
s'il avait fait
une chirurgie parfaite
en endormant
à dents,
anesthésie.
Et ensuite,
il a pris
de sa propre masse
de son corps
pour fermer aussi.
Et donc,
on voit
tous ces indices
qui aujourd'hui
sont utilisés
dans toutes les choses.
Et donc,
il y a plein
d'abordages
comme ça
que je trouve
vraiment très intéressants.
Mais pour l'instant,
pour gagner du temps,
je pense qu'il est mieux
de présenter
quelques arguments
qui vont aller
dans la direction
du créationisme biblique.
Car il y a
beaucoup d'arguments
scientifiques
apologétiques
qui s'occupent
tout simplement
à pointer
envers
une origine intelligente.
Le design intelligent,
par exemple,
qui est
une théorie
scientifique.
OK ?
Mais nous,
on est intéressés
non seulement
à une théorie
qui pointe
envers Dieu
tout simplement,
mais une théorie
qui se conforme
le plus qui est possible
au créationnisme biblique,
c'est-à-dire
Terre jaune aussi
qui a notre intérêt.
Et donc,
on a présenté
quelques éléments
philosophiques
ou cosmologiques.
Je vais juste vous citer
quelques-uns
qui ont apporté
pour ne pas revenir.
Donc,
les principes
des causalités,
donc tout ce qui existe,
ce qu'on observe
a une origine
en commencement
et donc
la préexistence
des choses
n'est pas possible
et la génération
spontanée
est logiquement
impossible.
L'existence
demande
l'auto-existence.
Donc,
s'il y a quelque chose
dans l'univers
aujourd'hui,
c'est car il y a un jour
quelque chose
à exister
pour toujours.
Celui qui a déclenché
doit avoir
une existence infinie.
Si on voit
une puissance
dans l'univers
et les maintiens
d'une puissance,
il y a aussi
une puissance.
S'il y a l'argument
qu'on appelle
téléologique,
on voit de l'intelligence
dans l'histoire,
dans les fonctionnements
de l'univers
et donc
l'intelligence
n'est jamais issue
de la non-intelligence
dans l'univers.
Donc,
s'il y a de l'intelligence,
si nous,
on voit de la personnalité
dans l'être humain,
les crises morales,
on voit par là aussi
ces aspects.
On a parlé
de l'argument
esthétique aussi.
Donc,
on voit que dans la création,
il y a
des fortes évidences
des beautés
et en nous,
dans l'être humain,
la capacité
d'identifier
la beauté.
Donc,
ça joue
beaucoup plus
envers
une beauté
intentionnelle
dans l'univers
plutôt qu'une beauté
aléatoire
qui pourrait expliquer
si tant de beauté
éparpillée
dans toute la création.
Et donc,
l'exigence
d'une cause
transcendantale
pour les temps
demande
quelqu'un
hors du temps.
Pour la matière,
c'est lui
qui a esprit.
Et pour l'espace,
quelqu'un
qui soit omniprésent
en qui
toutes les choses
puissent subsister.
Donc là,
on a considéré
ces arguments
qu'on appelle
cosmologiques.
On observe
les cosmos
de manière logique
et on arrive
à ces conclusions.
On a aussi parlé
beaucoup
de quelques évidences
physiques
ou de la physique.
Donc,
on a parlé
de la loi,
la deuxième loi
de la thermodynamique,
c'est-à-dire
l'univers,
il a une tendance
vers ce qu'ils appellent
l'entropie,
c'est-à-dire
les choses
à l'origine
avaient une ordre
et pour que l'ordre
soit maintenu,
il faut une intervention
ou un maintien
car lorsque toutes les choses
observables sont laissées
à elles-mêmes,
elles ont la tendance
à se défaire.
Donc,
c'est complètement contraire
à la théorie de l'évolution
où les choses
auront la tendance
à s'organiser
ou se refaire.
Donc,
c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose
qui est inséré
dans les présupposés
évolutionnistes.
Les choses auront
une tendance
à passer
de la simplicité
à la complexité
et ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qu'on puisse observer.
Toutes les choses
qui sont livrées
à elles-mêmes,
elles ont la tendance
à perdre soit
leur puissance,
soit à se dégrader.
Il y a aussi
l'impossibilité
de l'auto-organisation.
On peut prendre
tous les éléments
qu'on pourrait imaginer
ou vouloir
qu'ils puissent
engendrer la vie,
par exemple.
On peut prendre
tous les éléments
de la vie,
mettre dans un laboratoire,
chercher à reproduire
ces réactions chimiques,
mais on ne voit
jamais l'observation
d'une tendance
à que ces mélanges
passent envers
l'organisation
ou l'auto-organisation
et encore plus,
surtout,
que la vie
soit issue
de la non-vie.
Ça,
on n'a jamais vu.
Et là,
on a parlé aussi
de ce qu'on appelle
les fine-tuning
ou les propriétés fines
ou l'harmonisation
fine de l'univers.
Je vous ai expliqué
en fait que
pour que dans notre univers
on ait de la vie,
et pour qu'on ait
cet équilibre même
entre les planètes,
l'équilibre
qu'on va observer
dans l'espace,
quand on considère
tous les éléments
qu'on peut observer
dans les mondes
pour qu'ils soient
en train de vivre
dans un parfait équilibre,
donc juste un exemple
bête,
mais s'il y avait
plus de,
je pense que c'est
21% d'oxygène
dans l'air,
on pourrait exploser
et s'il y avait moins,
on serait étouffé.
Et donc,
il y a tout cet équilibre
de la couche atmosphérique,
l'approximation du soleil,
la distance entre les planètes,
etc.
Et on voit de manière
très claire
que pour que cet univers
soit engendré
de manière aléatoire
à cause de l'interdépendance
et de l'équilibre
qu'on observe
dans l'univers aujourd'hui,
et pour qu'il puisse
non seulement
apparaître
de manière aléatoire,
mais qu'il puisse aussi
être maintenu
de manière aléatoire,
la proportion,
c'est des,
là je vais noter aujourd'hui
car je ne vais pas arriver,
1 fois 10
à 1230.
Donc je ne sais même pas,
peut-être que ceux qui travaillent
avec la mathématique
peuvent nous aider
à visualiser la chose,
mais juste pour vous donner
quelques pistes,
il y a un critère
qui est appelé
les critères de Borel
qui nous dit
que si quelque chose
a une probabilité
de 1 fois 10
à moins 50,
elle est considérée
une impossibilité
scientifique.
C'est-à-dire,
c'est Émile Borel
qui a proposé
si tout événement
ayant une probabilité
inférieure à celle-ci
est considéré
comme une impossibilité
pratique.
Mais il y a
ceux qui sont encore
plus généreux,
il y a un autre critère
qui s'appelle
les critères
de l'ajustement
de l'univers,
pardon,
l'impossibilité
en physique statique,
statistique
et cosmologique
et donc eux,
ils vont dire
que c'est 1 fois 10
élevé à moins 120.
Et là,
juste pour vous donner
une idée,
on n'aurait pas
assez des particules
ni d'interactions
dans l'univers
pour qu'un tel événement
survienne par hasard.
C'est un nombre
qui dépasse même
toutes les particules
qui existent
dans l'univers
telle qu'il est
observable
par la science.
Et donc,
le nombre
des particules
dans l'univers
est de 1 fois 10
élevé
à 80.
Et donc ici,
moins 120,
c'est déjà
une impossibilité
que l'autre univers
puisse apparaître
de manière aléatoire
à partir d'une explosion
à cause de cette probabilité.
Il y a un livre
d'Arsys Plow
qui s'appelle
« Aucune chance,
pas de chance,
not a chance »
pour démontrer
que c'est impossible
que notre univers
puisse apparaître
à partir
de quelques phénomènes
hasardieux.
Donc,
logiquement,
scientifiquement,
c'est déjà une théorie
qui devra être considérée
comme impossible.
OK ?
Et donc là,
on avance
pour quelques évidences
de l'astronomie.
Et donc,
chacune des ces ères,
il y a encore
beaucoup d'autres évidences
que vous pouvez trouver,
mais on peut considérer
les évidences
de l'astronomie.
Quelques-unes,
bien sûr,
donc l'instabilité
des galaxies spirales.
Donc,
selon les critères
observés par la science,
il y a
la possibilité
qu'on voit
les signes
des spirales
dans les galaxies
telles qu'on voit
encore aujourd'hui.
à cause de la distance
qui s'apprend
pour qu'on puisse regarder,
suggère qu'elles sont
très récentes
car elles ne peuvent
pas tenir longtemps.
Et si l'univers
avait des milliers
et des milliers
de données,
on ne pourrait plus voir
ces types de galaxies.
C'est la même chose
par rapport
aux anneaux planétaires.
Si on voit
encore ces choses
et qu'elles existent
depuis des milliers
et des milliers
d'années,
on ne devrait pas
les voir.
Je ne vais pas rentrer
dans les détails,
je vous donne juste
les coordonnées
car on a déjà parlé
un peu plus
la semaine dernière
sur ça aussi.
On peut parler
de l'insuffisance
des collisions
météoriques
pour expliquer
l'ordre cosmique.
Donc là,
il y a cette théorie aussi
qui va dire
que l'univers
est encore en expansion
car on peut voir
des collisions
entre les météores
ou les tempêtes
d'astéroïdes
et la réalité
c'est que quand on observe
ce que se passe
avec les météores,
c'est la même chose
qu'on observe
si deux voitures
vont collisionner.
Et donc là,
c'est-à-dire,
bon,
exemple bête aussi,
mais on ne voit pas
deux voitures
qui s'entrecollident
former un camion
qui rentre en collision
s'éteindre
avec encore
plus belle complexité
et former
un beau camion
ou un bus.
Donc la réalité,
ce qu'on voit,
c'est que la collision,
elle ne génère pas
la complexité
ou l'expansion,
elle génère plutôt
la destruction
et le déséquilibre.
et la décroissance
du champ magnétique
terrestre
et planétaire.
Donc on observe
qu'il y a un critère
de diminution
des forces
de ces champs magnétiques
et si la Terre
ou les cosmos
étaient si vieux que ça,
on serait déjà
complètement détruit,
disparu.
Les évidences
de la biochimie
et les informations
biologiques.
Donc on va partir
du macro
envers les micros.
Donc l'un des arguments
les plus intéressants
c'est l'irréductibilité
et la complexité
des systèmes biologiques.
Donc très bête,
mais quand on voit
que Dieu a créé
les arbres,
avec un décalage
d'un jour
ou très peu de jours
entre les arbres
et les oiseaux,
les arbres,
les végétaux,
ils ont besoin
des oiseaux
pour continuer
d'exister,
pour féconder.
Et l'inverse
est aussi vérité,
pour se nourrir
les oiseaux.
Et donc l'homme
il est là
pour cultiver la terre,
la terre est là
pour nourrir l'homme.
Et donc si chaque jour
était désert,
aucun élément vivant
créé par Dieu
ne pourrait survivre
tous ces jours-là.
Si les nuits sont
par exemple
désertes,
des nuits,
c'est fini le soleil
pour les végétaux
et ils sont morts aussi.
Et donc la littéralité
de la proximité,
c'est notamment
à cause
de cette
irréductible
complexité
d'interaction
entre les choses
créées,
l'univers
avec les champs
gravitationnels
qui rendent
l'équilibre des choses
et aussi
les vies
qui sont là
dans la terre.
Mais il y a
l'irréductibilité
de la complexité
des systèmes biologiques
dans chaque être vivant.
Et donc par exemple,
quand on voit
et on observe
par exemple
une espèce
et on observe
une autre espèce
qui aurait développé
d'une autre,
par l'observation
de l'être humain
par exemple,
il y a
certains éléments
qui sont interdépendants
et qui auraient
besoin de se développer
au même temps
pour pouvoir
fonctionner correctement.
Donc l'œil humain
par exemple,
il exige
une complexité
d'interaction
avec d'autres
organes
biochimiques
ou biologiques
pardon
et si on n'a pas
cette évolution
au même temps
de plusieurs éléments,
on n'a pas
la possibilité
d'évolution
d'une espèce
à autre
dans ce sens-là.
Et donc ça
c'est aussi
très intéressant,
il y a beaucoup
des complexités
irréductibles
dans les systèmes
biologiques.
Donc certains
systèmes biochimiques
comme les flagelles
bactériens
ou la cascade
de la coagulation
du sang
sont trop complexes
pour être apparues
progressivement
par sélection
naturelle.
Ils nécessitent
plusieurs parties
interdépendantes
fonctionnant ensemble,
ce qui signifie
qu'une version
incomplète
de ces systèmes
pourrait
ne conférer
aucun avantage
sélectif.
il n'y a pas
comment évoluer.
L'impossibilité
de la génération
spontanée
de la vie,
donc l'apparition
de la première
cellule vivante
à partir
de matières
inertes,
exige
une séquence
incroyablement
complexe
d'événements
biochimiques.
Et donc là,
la probabilité
que cela arrive
n'est pas possible.
Des expériences
qui cherchaient
à reproduire
ces passages
n'ont jamais
produit
des structures
biologiques
viables.
Donc la science
n'a jamais pu
par ses expériences
reproduire la vie
à partir de la non-vie.
Donc l'impossibilité
de la génération
spontanée de la vie
c'est une donnée
observable.
Ce que la science
a enregistré
malgré toutes les théories
qu'ils peuvent inventer,
c'est qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à générer
la vie
à partir de la non-vie.
L'information
génétique
et ça c'est
vraiment incroyable,
c'est la complexité
de l'ADN.
Donc on a
des toutes petites
machines au-dedans
de nous
qui ont la capacité
non seulement
de décodifier
mais aussi
de transformer
l'information reçue
pour réagir
au fur et à mesure
que les choses apparaissent.
Donc l'analogie
avec un langage
ou un code informatique
est souvent utilisée
pour montrer
que l'ADN
suppose
un concepteur
intelligent.
Donc là,
on a au-dedans
de la réalité
des êtres vivants
une espèce
de capacité
de lecture
et de traduire
ou de réagir
à des commandes
qui sont reçues
à partir
de l'ADN.
Et donc quand on voit
toutes les informations
qui sont condensées
dans un ADN
et sa relation
avec
comment on appelle
les
comment vous appelez
en français
l'ADN
mitochondriale
et donc
c'est la manière
dont l'information
est reçue
et comment elle peut
réagir même
aux circonstances
qu'on voit.
Donc à partir de là
on peut penser
que Dieu a fait
un input
quand on dit
en français
il a déjà créé
par exemple
là
ça c'est intéressant
car ça joue
avec l'arche
de Noé
car
quand on voit
la possibilité
qu'un couple
de chaque
espèce
soit
dans l'arche
nous pensons
parfois
qu'on peut imaginer
un nombre
infini.
Donc c'est pas pour dire
que toutes les races
des chiens
sont là
mais c'est pour dire
que tout
un représentant
un couple
de représentants
de toutes les espèces
pourrait être là
car nous croyons
et nous affirmons
et c'est scientifique
de dire
que la micro-évolution
elle est possible
mais jamais
une évolution
des changements
d'espèces.
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
selon leur espèce
et ce que nous observons
c'est que nous pouvons
trouver toute une variété
d'une même espèce
car
en réaction
à l'environnement
auquel
elles sont exposées
elles peuvent
développer
certaines altérations
et il est très intéressant
dans la biochimique
de voir
les études
qu'ils font
pour démontrer
en fait
comment
l'ADN
il possède déjà
cette capacité
codifiée
pour qu'en réaction
à l'environnement
il puisse réagir.
Donc c'est comme si
on vivait
dans une réalité
à 4D
car il y a
des transformations
même physiques
qui peuvent avoir lieu
quand on est exposé
à certaines choses.
Mais là
ce sont des indices
que Dieu a déjà
codifié même
les possibilités
de variation
de ces espèces.
Mais jamais
des mutations
qui puissent
sauter
d'espèces.
On n'a jamais vu ça,
on n'a jamais eu
des indices
des données
scientifiques
pour prouver ça.
Il y a un argument
génétique
très intéressant
aussi
à cet égard
qui a été développé
plutôt récemment
et qui a été appelé
l'Ève
mitochondriale
et ça c'est
très intéressant.
Donc l'ADN
mitochondrial
est hérité
exclusivement
de la mère
et ça permet
de retracer
la lignée maternelle
de toute l'humanité.
on peut
passer
examiner
chaque individu
et on identifie
et on peut
apprendre
à calculer
des études
génétiques
arrivent
à identifier
une femme
ancestrale
unique
qu'ils ont appelée
Ève mitochondriale
notamment car
il y a beaucoup
de similarités
avec l'évidence publique
par rapport à Ève
et l'époque
de sa vie.
Donc initialement
les évolutionnistes
estimaient
son existence
à environ
200 000 ans
en se basant
sur un taux
des mutations
supposés
qui était faible.
Cependant,
des recherches
réévaluant
les taux réels
des mutations
ont montré
que la Ève
mitochondriale
pourrait avoir
vécu
il y a seulement
6 000 ans
ou 10 000 ans.
Et donc nous croyons
bien sûr
que la Bille
nous présente
6 000 ans
et donc on peut
avec une certaine
mesure
d'exactitude
de fiabilité
déduire
par la mesure
de ces taux
réels
des mutations
qu'il y a eu
une Ève
une mère
qui a vécu
il y a
entre 6 000 ans
et 10 000 ans.
Et donc on peut
rester avec les 6 000 ans
car on sait
que c'est la réalité.
Et donc
la localisation
probable
de cette mère
commune
était
en Afrique
du Nord-Ouest
là où
tout a commencé
qui correspond
en zone proche
du Moyen-Orient
d'où les peuples
ont migré
après la dispersion
des Babels.
Donc c'est très intéressant
de voir comment
la science
est en train
de nous donner
de données
très spécifiques.
Et tout comme
il y a
ce qu'on appelle
l'ADN mitochondrial
Ève
nous avons aussi
aujourd'hui
l'ADN
chromosomique
Y.
Je ne sais pas
si vous avez
déjà entendu parler
mais l'ADN
du chromosome
Y
il est transmis
uniquement par les pairs
des pairs
en fils
et permet
de rétracer
la lignée
paternelle
de l'humanité.
De manière similaire
à l'Ève
mitochondriale
des études
ont identifié
un ancêtre
masculin
commun
qui a été
appelé
Adam Y
à cause
de la similité
avec la Bible.
Et donc
les premières
estimations
évolutionnistes
plaçaient
Adam
entre 100 000
ans
et 200 000
mais des calculs
plus précis
basés sur
des taux
de mutation
actuels
ont réduit
cette estimation
à quelques
milliers
d'années.
Et donc
les faits
qu'Adam
chromosomique
et Ève
mitochondriale
soient déjà
des données
scientifiques
pour nous
aujourd'hui
renforcent
davantage
cette réalité.
Nous pourrions
aussi
considérer
les études
qui font
les scientifiques
liées à la dispersion
des peuples
donc par la génétique
des populations
par la diversité
génétique
croissante
et nous
retrassons
cet éloignement
qui retrace
toutes les choses
au Moyen-Orient
post-tour
de la migration
des Babels.
Et donc là
il y a plein
d'indices aussi
à cet égard
pour ce qui
concerne
voilà
pas que la biologie
mais aussi
les arguments
des migrations
des peuples.
Donc
il y a aussi
des évidences
géologiques
est-ce qu'il y a
un H là ?
J'imagine
et la paléontologie
ou non ?
Est-ce qu'il y a
ou pas ?
Ok.
Et là
je pense que c'est
là où se joue
le plus
la propagande
évolutionniste.
Comment
mesurer
l'âge
de la Terre ?
On va
étudier
les extraits
géologiques,
les couches
géologiques.
C'est là
on va dire
qu'on va
mesurer
les fossiles
par rapport
aux animaux
qui on va...
C'est comme si
chaque couche
géologique
des terres
avec les fossiles
représentait
un H de la Terre.
Et donc
ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que
les personnes
parfois
elles vont chercher
à mesurer
la datation
à cause
de la perte
des magnétiques
par exemple
ou par rapport
à des indices
comparatifs
à d'autres traces
qu'on trouve
dans d'autres endroits.
Mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que par exemple
quand on va
les montagnes
en général
on va proposer
que ça a pris
des milliers
et des milliers
d'années
pour engendrer
quelques montagnes
mais c'est intéressant
il y a eu
une éruption
très importante
en 1980
qui a engendré
ce qu'on appelle
les monts
Centelle.
et les monts
ou la montagne
Centelle
elle était apparue
comme une montagne
vraiment très très grande
et si elle serait datée
par un scientifique
selon les critères actuels
il devrait
en regardant
la montagne
et en mesurant même
la démanétisation
des pierres
qui après
les catastrophes
ou les cataclysmes
traversent
des expériences
chimiques
physiques
qui vont
altérer
énormément
leur état
donc pour nous
qui croyons
dans la terre
jeune
nous savons
que Dieu
a pu créer
toutes les choses
avec l'apparence
d'âge
déjà
donc Adam
là on revient au point
mais Adam
il a été créé
apparemment
avec l'âge
de 20 ans
ou 30 ans
mais en réalité
il n'avait
qu'il y a
un jour
et la même chose
Dieu a fait
la végétation
qui était là
bon si je vais
étudier chaque arbre
et essayer
de mesurer son âge
par les anneaux
qu'il y a là
on sait très bien
qu'il y a eu des arbres
qui Dieu a poussé
qui a accéléré
sa croissance
et donc
l'univers
il peut avoir
l'apparence d'âge
on peut mesurer
la vitesse
avec laquelle
les choses
vont s'est détériorées
mais la Bible
elle nous enseigne aussi
qu'il y a eu
des événements
cataclysmatiques
cataclysmiques
très importants
dans l'histoire
donc les déluges
c'était
l'un des événements
les plus impactants
on n'a pas l'idée
vraiment
de combien violent
il était
et combien
plusieurs montagnes
sont apparues
après
les déluges
ou pendant
car on se demande
mais comment
l'eau aurait pu
couvrir toute la terre
si on va
à toutes ces montagnes
mais la violence
du déluge
a provoqué
par exemple
la congélation
très accélérée
à cause de la chaleur
qui a été provoquée
et qui explique
en fait
qu'il y a
plusieurs régions
qui sont en train
de souffrir
comment on dit ça
les dégelements
c'est comme si
la terre
était encore
en train
de se rétablir
de cette période
donc c'est surprenant
de voir les lieux
où on a cru
qu'il était
on va dire
l'air de la glace
il n'y avait
aucune vie
sur ces endroits
mais à partir
du moment
où les choses
sont en train
de s'effondre
on commence
à voir des signes
de vie
des fossiles
des choses
qui montrent clairement
qui à un moment donné
ce n'était pas ça
ce n'est pas comme si
ça était toujours
de la glace
et que ça commence
à fondre
ça explique plus
un événement
cataclysmique
qui a produit
ces choses
donc les datations
sont très contradictoires
par rapport aux rochers
car ils utilisent
beaucoup de critères
de datation différents
et donc il y a
ces problèmes
avec les datations
car ils ne les prennent
pas en considération
et leur présupposé
c'est déjà
une longue date
ils ont besoin
de ça
donc il y a
la datation aussi
incohérente
des couches géologiques
donc il y a
un épisode
qui est appelé
l'explosion
cambrienne
qui désigne
l'apparition
soudaine
et massive
des formes
de vie complexes
et des fossiles
où ils supposent
que cette explosion
a eu lieu
entre 530
et 540 millions
d'années
donc pour
essayer d'expliquer
un peu plus clair
quand ils étudient
les couches
géologiques
ils ont trouvé
dans une de ces couches
qui était censée
avoir
530 millions
d'années
ensemble
des éléments
qui vivent
très proches
et qui auraient dû
prendre
des milliers
de milliers
pour évoluer
dans l'autre
mais ils les trouvent
tous au même endroit
dans la même couche
et ça c'est un grand défi
pour la science
car ils n'arrivent pas
à conformer ça
c'est appelé
l'explosion
cambrienne
et nous par exemple
si on croit
comme on croit
au déluge
et qu'il y a
des déluges
il est vraiment
quelque chose
qui explique l'histoire
pour nous
de manière très importante
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment on peut
expliquer
là il y a
beaucoup d'indices
géologiques
des couches
qui ont été
produites
très vite
l'une sur l'autre
sans que la transition
soit
on va dire
plus érosive
plus souple
la transition
elle est vraiment
très marquée
car ça explique
plutôt
des événements
cataclysmiques
où une montagne
est versée
sur une région
par exemple
et donc c'est clair
si on imagine ici
j'ai envie de faire
cette expérience
avec mes enfants
mais si on imagine ici
qu'on avait la mer
et les déloges
commencent à venir
et qu'ils poussent
une montagne
sur une autre montagne
et qu'ils tous
viennent dans cette direction
c'est clair
et c'est intéressant aussi
car
je vais révéler
si c'est pour un peu
après
mais par exemple
c'est clair
que les animaux
qui seront ici-bas
morts
directement
seront les animaux
de la mer
ceux-ci seront
plutôt les amphibies
et c'est plus clair
d'expliquer
de manière
plus catamnétique
non une explication
de l'évolution
mais des indices
dans des louges
par exemple
et en plus
ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il y a
des éléments
qu'on trouve
à propos des
comment on dit
des
empreintes
oui mais les pieds
comment on appelle
les empreintes
elles sont très proches
des fossiles
et normalement
les fossiles
pour qu'ils soient
si vieux que ça
il faut que les empreintes
soient déjà disparues
et c'est très intéressant
de voir comment
parfois
ça prouve
en fait
qu'ils habitaient
dans des périodes
vraiment très récentes
des nues
pour qu'on soit capable
de tracer
leurs empreintes
avec leurs fossiles
et les fossiles
ils ne peuvent pas
être expliqués non plus
car pour qu'un fossile
s'efforne
car on sait
que toutes les choses
qui sont mortes
naturellement
et qu'elles soient dégradées
elles vont disparaître
assez facilement
ils ne peuvent qu'être
expliqués par des événements
catacrysmiques
il faut que ça soit
une mort soudaine
qu'ils soient vraiment
en prenser
par la nature
donc il y a plein
d'évidence aussi
très intéressante
envers ça
et plus récemment aussi
il y a un cas
où ils ont découvert
dans un corne
des dinosaures
du tissu
et ils étaient tous
vraiment surpris
car c'est impossible
qu'un tissu
avec des
de l'ADN
des évidences
fraîches
soit encore présente
et donc
on peut croire
comme la Bible nous présente
qu'on a eu
des dinosaures
qui habitaient avec nous
et dont la majorité
a été
a été exterminée
à la période
de déluge
donc l'explication
catastrophique
et les évidences
catastrophiques
c'est-à-dire
qui pointent envers
en délouge
par exemple
elles sont
très évidentes
donc ensuite
les évidences
paléotologiques
il y a
les manques
des fossiles
transitionnels
donc on n'a jamais
trouvé
désolé
les français
concernant
des vocabulaires
plus techniques
hors de mon
habitude
théologique
c'est plus dur
merci
mais
la chaîne manquante
ok
les chaînes manquantes
c'est un grand problème
aussi
à l'intérieur
même
de ces théories
donc ce qu'ils appellent
les manques
des fossiles
transitionnaires
les fossiles
trouvés
dans des couches
supposées
trop anciennes
ou trop récentes
voilà
j'ai déjà parlé
à propos des emprunts
liés aux fossiles
oui
et les plus durs
pour eux
c'est quand on trouve
dans la même couche
des animaux
qui étaient censés
être
beaucoup plus profonds
dans la terre
mais qui sont là
avec les autres
qui sont aussi
très souvent trouvés
les fossiles
d'arbres
pétrifiés
verticaux
des troncs
d'arbres
fossilisés
traversent
plusieurs couches
sédimentaires
suggérant
un effouissement
rapide
plutôt
qu'une sédimentation
progressive
sur des millions
d'années
fossiles
trouvés
dans des couches
supposées
trop anciennes
donc j'ai déjà parlé
donc voilà
et pour conclure
il y a
les évidences
anthropologiques
sociologiques
en faveur
du créationnisme
biblique
donc déjà
l'homme
être un phénomène
religieux
la plus grande
crise
psychologique
philosophique
de nos jours
les relativismes
les manques
de sens
c'est car
on a voulu
supprimer
car
il n'y a
aucune explication
pour la spiritualité
humaine
si on n'a pas été
créé par Dieu
si on est les fruits
d'une explosion
on doit supprimer
ces choses
et c'est surtout
à partir de là
qu'on voit comment
c'est la corruption
du cœur roman
qui cherche
à échapper
des dieux
comme la Bible
nous parle
à plusieurs reprises
et donc
roman chapitre 1
il nous dit clairement
les personnes
en préférant
l'injustice
elles ont supprimé
l'évidence
des dieux
donc quel est
l'intérêt
pour ces personnes-là
nous sommes corrompus
moralement
et s'il n'y a pas
un absolu moral
pour nous empêcher
de nous livrer
à nos corruptions
on préfère vivre
dans un monde
relatif
où on va voter
à propos des choses
qui sont correctes
ou non
en pouvant permettre
qu'on pratique
par exemple
les sexes
sans responsabilité
et qu'on commette
l'avortement
car il n'y a pas
d'absolu moral
donc ça va
dans toutes ces directions
les raisons réelles
derrière
l'envie
de ne pas reconnaître
la réalité
mais l'homme
il reste un phénomène
un phénomène religieux
depuis toujours
depuis tout l'enregistrement
de l'histoire
donc c'est ça
qui est intéressant
quand ils disent
dans la préhistoire
mais comment
pouvons-nous parler
de la préhistoire
si nous n'avons
que l'histoire
c'est-à-dire
l'abbé nous dit
l'homme
il existe depuis 6 000 ans
et depuis 6 000 ans
nous avons
des enregistrements
historiques
et avant ça
c'est plus toi
c'est plus observation
c'est plus scientifique
et donc là
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
depuis l'enregistrement
les plus anciens
de l'histoire
nous avons
que les civilisations
sont en quête
pour la moralité
en rapport
envers leur conscience
ce sont des personnes
tout simplement
et quand on considère
et on compare
la complexité
philosophique
qu'on va trouver
même dans les temps anciens
et qu'on compare
avec aujourd'hui
au moins l'être humain
c'est évident
qu'on n'est pas
en train d'évoluer
en termes des valeurs
en termes des complexités
donc c'est
c'est les contraires
des évidences
donc il y a
la crise des finitudes
on a déjà abordé
il y a des indices
par rapport
à la migration
des peuples
qui pointent envers
les Moyen-Orients
comme on a déjà vu
il y a
l'évidence
des types sanguins
qui peuvent tous
être issus
dans le même couple
là c'est un autre problème
si on dit
que l'homme
est développé
d'un animal
pour la reproduction
c'est l'un des éléments
les plus complexes
pour distinguer
une espèce
de l'autre
il y a aussi
les défis
qu'un homme
et une femme
soient développés
au même temps
au même endroit
pas dans des lieux différents
donc l'unité
de la race humaine
elle est claire
et on a parlé
d'autres évidences
mais aussi
les types sanguins
l'origine commune
des langues
donc ceux qui étudient
la philologie
ils peuvent tracer
une langue commune
de laquelle
toutes les autres
langues
sont originées
et voilà
donc on peut
s'arrêter ici
je ne sais pas
si vous avez des questions
si on a des temps
pour les questions
mais l'argument
pour les christianismes
pour les créationnismes
bibliques littérales
il est
en général
dans la conclusion
de ces livres
ils vont présenter
l'argument
cumulatif
pour les créationnismes
littéraux
de la terre jeune
c'est-à-dire
il est cumulatif
car
si on prend
chacune de ces évidences
elles seraient déjà
de soi-même
très importantes
pour pointer
envers les créationnismes
bibliques littérales
mais quand on prend
l'ensemble
de ces évidences
cumulatives
c'est là
on va revenir
à la question
de la probabilité
l'impossibilité
que ça ne soit pas
comme ça
qui est dû écrire
toutes les choses
les choses